citizens of the reject nation we are
here today to watch cobra kai
season five episode five extreme
measures
john how's it going it's going great
andrew it is also going great andrew
gossey's shirts forgot to mention in the
last episode thank you andrew thank you
you're welcome you're welcome my
pleasure guys i'm grateful anyway we are
going to watch this uh leave a like that
would be very much appreciated subscribe
click that notification bell to get
notified when a reaction for the next
episode is up here on the channel and as
always following threats and watch long
as we sync up with your own copy
available at our patreon page for super
sexy rejects the team of prepper thank
you for helping us edit down these
highlights let's do this
[Music]
yeah i was just thinking about stingray
my man
that was a new place you settling in oh
yeah yeah
yes sensei
thank you god i'm a new place i want my
loyal soldier living in style it's the
least i could do in light of your
sacrifice
and i tend to do more than the least
oh holy [ __ ]
was it worth it
but it should be a stingray
check the trunk
oh
nice
tell you what i'm gonna get you guys a
basket of bread sticks fresh out of the
oven i'll come right back down and
all right guys i do have good
breadsticks breadsticks aren't gonna fix
this spoken like a man who's never had
the garden's breadsticks one bite you
forget why you were ever mad each other
in the first place yeah i'm never gonna
forget that neither am i
at least have some bread sticks
oh garden got a good promotion there
they paid for that whole scene in fact
i'm gonna go there after this
oh you know seriously he's got some
facial hair yeah i don't think we've
ever seen him without facial hair and
his hair is not perfectly combed
with mirror
no envelope for all we know this is just
silver sending us out on a wild goose
chase so he could screw up my life even
worse
could be
would be stingray you sure don't come to
dinner no you and your cousin should
catch up okie dokie
oh
is that robin lively
from karate kid part three
yes
definitely it is and yes that's why
you're here
jessica andrews oh what's all of this i
don't worry about it i want a beer
cactus
you literally just said he wasn't here
yeah i lied again not my fault you fell
for it twice
[Laughter]
[Music]
found a bunch of strategies for building
trust and teamwork through cooperative
exercises the least lame one is called
an escape room
[Laughter]
i reverse the door knobs it's a lot from
the inside
and
how are they gonna get out now i mean
you two have your thing whatever but you
keep forcing this all you're gonna do is
get his ass kicked oh ready when you are
runner-up and the time in the place oh
my god you guys i am billy the kid and i
have a video for you
just fight it out guys yeah you'll feel
better
chris put this guy in a coma and now
he's driving around on a cobra kai
billboard on wheels
put him in a coma
beat him up for real in the wreckage of
my life
[Music]
there's a nice sony uh tie in there with
a ps4 sensei silver is an honorable man
and he felt terrible for whatever sensei
silver came after my family that's the
kind of man he is well if that is true
then you must have done
something to deserve it all right you're
gonna give me a goddamn straight answer
no no
not the ps4
my playstations who gives a [ __ ] about
your playstation danielson
enough
you are not yourself you're a bully
daniel it's always been a hothead
now terry's gonna have to get him a ps5
this guy's never gonna help us
but i know someone who can
hillary swing i knew it
hey
chris sakes
amanda steiner hey lizzie ann remember
she was the one that beat up that car
with the baseball bat ah
nickname that we gave you after that god
it was so good but god i wish i could
remember you know but it's so long ago
you know we're gonna catch up it was
good talk fight them
you have to open it from out there
oh my god oh
i washed my hands of the cobra kai thing
when we lost a tournament what you you
started the whole cobra kai thing
if you hadn't brought it back none of
this would be happening you opened
pandora's box not me listen i don't know
who pandora is or what's in her box
you don't want to know what happened to
the strike first badass huh do i need to
kick his ass to wake him up or it was
just one tournament loss all it took to
turn you into
oh my god
what are you doing uh
raving like a lunatic eureka booze and
now you're gonna fight me cause i don't
wanna get pulled back into this rivalry
with silver
what's going on with you man
nice i like that
if you think i'm off the rails
way off
she's got the pierce
[Music]
jenga beer
she's at her mother's in ohio she took
the kids with her
ah that makes sense jessica andrews ohio
yeah karate kid three we know
easter eggs mess you up andrew terry
silver he was hosting a charity funk
sorry
terry
silver is back
i understood that reference
[Music]
first he pretended to be his friend
then his mentor
hey come on guys while his goons wrecked
his bonsai shop
beat him up
they assaulted me
but he got past it back then so
he can get past it now right
yeah except he didn't really get past it
then did he
goddamn
robbie moved in for a bit now him and
miguel are at each other's throats again
this is my dumb idea to try to get him
to iron it out but it crashed and burned
so much for goggles advice on conflict
resolution goggles google
you know maybe that's how we should have
done it all those years ago if we hadn't
had to stop at three points we might
have gotten this all out of our systems
exactly three points is all you had in
you
there he is
all right on that note
should he be driving
should uh do ride show with johnny
can you give me a lift home babe
ruthless
break that beer bottle on her head
thanks for the trip down memory lane oh
oh i'm sorry does miss coastal elite not
like to be reminded of where she came
from blow it out your ass rooney
why don't you make me
andrews
stay in your lane steiner this is a bar
not a yoga class so unless you've got a
bat hiding behind that bony butt of
yours i don't need a bat for you [ __ ]
stamp
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
jesus christ do it same
it's not worth losing my family over
i have failed you
nah man it's not you
defending honor of miyagido
never a waste of time
no is helping friend
oh here it is fight fight
[Music]
i love how those are the only two that
came out oh okay
yeah i was like you two stay put are you
kidding me down how many times go ahead
yeah yeah
at least be men about it and put your
fist where your mouths are
we want us to do what
fight it out don't even get a stretch
warm-up
what here now
that's a time this is a place i'm sure
carmen's cool with this
they both end up hospitalized
good parenting
is that all you got
thought you guys were sworn enemies
nice
hell yeah
oh
it's getting real
uh-oh nobody makes me bleed my own blood
oh my god his back
[Music]
oh sheeps
[Music]
it's not a bad fight at all
christ oh my god please stay off the
second level
oh i'm so worried right now
i like how johnny's just sitting down
there oh my god oh my god
[ __ ]
get a mattress out dude
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
yikes
did we just become best friends
yep
i mean i barely knew where we were
i'd take it back in a second if i could
i mean i was the cause of the worst
moment in your life
and if it's any consolation it was the
worst moment of my life too
is it over
you guys good
oh thank god cause if you still hated
each other when the baby gets here
[Music]
like you and my mom
yeah we're
having a baby
we're supposed to tell you together so
make sure you act surprised holy
[ __ ] subversion of expectations
[Music]
that's awesome
the sam whoo girl's got skills
well it's in her blood i guess
so is uh
protecting her loved ones
that one she gets from the both of you
and the larger point you're clearly
trying to make it
daniel on the other hand
has every reason
to hate terry silver after what he put
him through you're saying i should cut
him some slack
yeah
that's exactly what i'm saying
what about johnny
diggins
oh they got the breadsticks i hope it's
cool i'm having dinner here
it's very cool
you're welcome anytime here robbie
oh this is so touching yeah that's so
sweet
these guys are getting along now how did
you manage that
and please don't tell me the bruises on
their faces mean that you beat them into
submission no of course not they beat
each other into submission
[Laughter]
it was actually larussa's idea
i didn't know you and daniel were
working together again
we weren't
but i think we might need to
hmm
i got your new playstation
if it's not a ps5 it's no good yep it
sucks it's remarkable how easy it was to
disrupt your marriage imagine how easy
it's going to be
to wrap cobra kai keys
around both your kids
yeah oh [ __ ]
it's not good
that's it larusso that's the kobrakai
student i remember
use the pressure points
oh
[Music]
oh my god what the hell
doing a michael myers trick on him
you bit off more than you could chill
and now that the writing's on the wall
you want to surrender
no no no
we are way past the time for white flags
danny boy
oh nice work holy [ __ ]
tricks
remind me of bane and dark knight rises
[ __ ]
[Music]
where's chosen
i want you alive
and well for what's about to happen
because the real pain
is above
to begin
to the pain
damn
god damn it
it's only getting worse
talking to chris
therapy he's imprisoned
nah she's pretty sure she's visiting
chris
and i'm delivering anonymous notes that
can put people in danger
huh damn there must be another way
or at least somebody else out there who
wants to be in this fight it was just
[ __ ] personal yeah
goddamn
there is an endgame kid
silver's going down
only he doesn't know it yet
i've taught all the prisoners karate
going down by recruiting hillary swing
dude greg is calling it it's gonna
happen
cause
yeah he'll get beat by girl and he'll be
super humility swink it up swank spank
let's go swank a tank
swink attack
all right
go go i know you want to speak uh well
couple the references obviously the the
uh easy ones are jessica andrews from
karate kid part three robin lively uh we
did hear part three
i said part three uh
we got uh i don't think you said it
several times
okay karate kid sorry guys sorry karate
kid part three jessica andrews uh we got
uh they went to ohio which is where we
heard she was from in the first film i
kind of mentioned that already and then
also we heard them uh talking about
climbing uh which of course we remember
in the fir in the third film which uh
her and daniel did a few times and we
saw the picture of her with her
boyfriend that she likes to climb uh in
the mountains and then also we saw
obviously the reference that they showed
us with danny uh
making his knuckles get bloody which is
also a reference of course to karate kid
part two and chris is trying to punch
miyagi and he gets the bloody knuckles
as well
so yeah those are the references i got
in regards to this episode uh wow
even though terry silver is not a very
big part of this episode he's more
towards the end again his influence
on this episode is is very much felt and
i love that and i love again just how
much he's broken daniel up until the uh
not only physically but just mentally
and spiritually i mean we've never seen
daniel this low uh there's obviously a
point in season two
at the end of season two and in season
three where the dealership's not doing
well and amanda was really upset with
him in season two uh where she was kind
of like not talking to him because he
wasn't doing well balancing between the
dojo and between their marriage
so she was kind of giving him the cold
shoulder but this is a different level
and it just shows again the power of
terry silver not only physically but
just again how he's just able to
manipulate daniel and even in an episode
where he's only you know shown at the
end
just how much he's broken daniel it's
just i thought it was a very interesting
you know uh way of showing like just
seeing daniel never seen him i mean
again karate kid part three we saw that
he really suffered from a lot of you
know anxiety and anger and really just
couldn't control himself and just wanted
to uh you know had a lot of like i said
a lot of anger problems that he had in
that film but
it's just i thought it was really
interesting and ralph macchio got to
show off that acting range that he has
and i really thought it was fascinating
watching daniel struggle with that
throughout this episode i mean just
seeing him with facial hair i was like
wow it's a different look for daniel and
i appreciate that and thought ralph
macchio really carried this episode and
was great and i really loved too that
scene he had with johnny where it kind
of flipped itself where in seasons one
through four or even uh or one through
three i would guess because in season
four johnny cleaned up his act but
usually johnny was the drunk one and
daniel was the sober one and you know
would give him like hey you should do
this or do that so that's why the
writers and the creators of the show are
so brilliant how they're able to you
know reverse things and and do things
differently but in a very satisfying and
emotionally paid-off way that i really
deeply appreciate and also too
i think johnny missed his call as a
therapist
that was impressive what he did with
robbie and miguel and i even though
the resolve was kind of quick even
though they did fight it out and i i
know that has been proven over time like
hey just just fight it up put some
boxing gloves on just fight it out you
guys will uh you know let out your
stress and your and your hatred towards
each other you'll be friends afterwards
i know that's a somewhat of a proven
technique uh with children of all ages
but um greg's like yeah that's what we
you guys do exactly i'll just let you
beat me to a pulp but i i actually did i
actually i actually even though the
result even though the resolve was very
quickly done i actually did buy that i
mean we've been building to
kind of the redemption arc of these two
like
maybe just not becoming best friends or
per se but at least just having a res
mutual respect for one each other when
it comes to miguel and robbie and i
thought it was very well executed and
done in a very satisfying way to the
point where i was like you know what i
buy this
i'd buy that for a dollar robocop
reference and also too i did like that
we got a little bit of the backstory as
well with uh amanda seeing like oh
that's how she met daniel it was through
to the love intro or i guess not the
love interest but the female character
from karate kid part three
i thought that was really well done and
the well told and uh also too uh one
more reference we got where they were
talking about her beating the bat on the
car of the teacher we heard amanda tell
that to daniel in last season because
where she was trying to tell daniel why
she's helping out tori's because she
suffered from a lot of anger problems in
high school she said that her i believe
it was her father or mother i can't
remember one of them was going out with
uh her history or uh teacher so that we
kind of got a little bit of the payoff
there and her name was baby uh babe
ruthless or something like that ruthless
yeah so
yeah
i like everything you said thank you
that was really well put thank you
i appreciate your insights and uh no
would not have recognized her right away
the way you did robin lively
yeah yes
so from karate kid part three part three
that's the one the third one make sure
it's the right part of three
is that yeah i would definitely whenever
they played the music as if it was a
character that i should know yeah and i
was like i don't know what that is you
thought it was hilary swank oh he's like
hillary strength looks different than
ever
and seen her in the movie her whole
facial structure has changed
so you being here was really helpful
because as much as they did establish it
later on
definitely wasn't an instant recognition
on my end
she looks a little different
a little older a little older but it
still looks good
yeah everybody in that in that uh you
know class aged
well oh
go ahead
why don't you go no no no no
okay you go you go i'll find the thing
you guys did not talk about you're a
bread stick i could always take it out
take it away uh yeah i think it's
interesting that this season is putting
people it i i guess it's
sho i don't know this feels like kind of
a random thread so so bear with me but i
feel like this season is also showing
just how easy it is for altercations to
stir up and for people to escalate
things because especially amanda has
been
you know more of the pacifist of the
show and even she winds up in a position
that's very relatable to everybody else
so i feel like that
then in combination with uh the whole
info dump about like no no no you don't
understand what terry silver did to
daniel like those two things together uh
while you could say like wow
it's perfect timing that you went on
this trip and got in a fight but at the
same time i think they're good at tying
together those like convenient timeline
things to make it work within the magic
of the show
and uh yeah i love the whole conflict
resolution arc and that they committed
to that like at first i was like i don't
know i don't know exactly i guess this
is more for johnny uh but to have that
one two three
of like okay let's sit down and talk
okay that doesn't work all right let's
uh change the focus and still work
together okay you know what in
i thought it was interesting that in a
show that clearly isn't trying to
promote the cobra kai lifestyle is a
show that's not trying to go like fight
all your problems physically
i think it is interesting to at least
admit that like hey for certain people
and in certain situations maybe that is
the simplest answer and while that's you
know surely problematic especially for
an adult to supervise two kids beating
each other up
at the same time i don't know
philosophically i'm like that is an
interesting point because they might not
have gotten there any other way because
this is a language they both understand
and they both are very immersed in
uh so yeah i don't know i just continue
to enjoy the geography of all the
different characters and uh
you know we'll see where stingray goes
from here
i was like where is he where would terry
silver just like put him in a box i was
about to mention at the end of this
episode if they didn't show him like are
we gonna get that payoff to what
happened with stingray but i answered it
right away
beginning of the episode
probably just hiding
i'll just wait up here until you feel
this place don't play ps5 and i think we
also established terry silver doesn't
really have that much money couldn't
even afford to get him a ps5 like broke
ass [ __ ] yeah dude that's the tell
right there
um even i got ps5 [ __ ] terry silver
terry silver if you're watching i'll
i'll take a piece
yeah i think with this episode it was so
much about um
you know uh
learning empathy by stepping in each
other's shoes you know like like you
pointed out with the role reversal of
johnny and danny
and um
and then of course with like amanda
having the bar situation
and then i have a surprise that she
didn't hear the uh in-depth story of the
history of terry silver she never heard
it before yeah i was like it took your
cousin telling you this
i thought danny would have surely have
told you what happened at one point yeah
that would be the most convincing way to
sway you to his arc because you didn't
seem to you didn't seem to really tell
that much more than what i imagined
daddy could have outlined for you at
some point in this timeline
um
because you know i'm like yeah it's
really effective when you're seeing
flashbacks and stuff but amanda's not
seeing the flashbacks we are so i don't
to me i don't know to me i was like i
really thought daniel would have told
you all this by this certain point
and uh yeah just getting to have
different experiences and understanding
something i think the show does really
well which is showing you the opposite
sides or showing you the gray sides of
things even with like samantha coming in
to defend her mom
in that bar fight bringing that out of
her reminding her of the good of karate
that in this real life world which is
the world cobra kai really hones in on
is that there's always going to be
[ __ ] and bullies and if you know how
to defend yourself that's not such a bad
thing actually
it's just that sometimes within even the
ones who learn to defend
breeds more bullying in some way so uh
yeah i thought like the thematically
what they did was awesome and i i just i
feel like every episode has kind of made
me like cry a little bit
yeah so far definitely it was really i
was really moved by everything with
robbie and johnny uh robbie and miguel
uh like their fight was really good i
like i think like those two actors have
definitely been training
and uh it shows in their fight
choreography
but
again you know like you're really all
about terry
i've been so much about miguel
i'm a cobra kind man you're all over the
place robbie yeah i've obviously i love
all the characters
uh when it like miguel when he had the
chance to pretty much get his revenge
and and knock robbie over the railing
like that was getting me emotional of
just like man all that
all that like anguish because this guy
is like so nice man
but he's got so much like
anger and hurt underneath
that
that demeanor he's constantly wearing
because he is a good kind-hearted kid at
the end of the day and so you know to
see all that pain being unleashed within
him but then making the choice
to not go through with it i i thought it
was just so moving i agree i'm just
something as simple as i'm sitting at
the table and being like yeah you can
come get me emotional right now like you
you can come here anytime you want
robbie just that sense of acceptance and
connection and
familial love like that [ __ ] really tugs
in my heart so i i thought it like
there's
this this episode in particular did a
quite a mastery and i felt like what
they're doing with daniel made the most
it really clicked with me this episode
after losing everything and really
becoming washed up and five o'clock
shadowed
trying to make
threatening the stingray and watching
how he's uh yeah just giving so much
into his anger but then you know even
kind of going against my own point when
it does complement the flashbacks you're
like you know
yeah terry silver guy could have left a
real traumatic impression on that kid
really could have because he he lured
him in under very false pretenses like i
could i could be the one who's your best
friend and help you and show you a new
way but it was really
like you put all your trust into someone
to find out it was all just this one big
lie to crumble you
um
yeah that that would be just
very devastating so suddenly knowing how
like triggered he is because it can seem
like danny just kind of has a new
replacement villain every time which is
just villains from the original trolls
it can seem like he has a new villain
replacement every time
um you know from johnny to crease
because you're like well i feel like
crease would be really but crease was
the difference with them is they were
always dicks you know whereas terry
like
messed with your heart
yeah and so that actually put it into a
much
better perspective for me of like oh
yeah this makes a lot of sense why this
is like really ruining him
um and it's something that i didn't even
consider of how much that negative
effect would be even stronger than
someone like a crease or a johnny
because john was kind of like a burden
and then and chris was like the head
honcho of like the bad face that he
always knew of but terry was a very
specific case
and to actually use what's the
character's name jessica jessica andrews
yeah she was like a detective
yeah she was in karate kid part three
she was crying kid three right not
karate kid the next guarded kid with the
hilary swank that was chosen
the bad guy in that movie was michael
ironside
[Music]
yeah it was like from an actual tv show
and then tarantino stapled it on to kill
[ __ ] that's a field song kill bill
compose for kill bill yeah i just want
to know one thing that wonderful scene
we got with robbie and miguel where you
know miguel made that you know that
mature choice and
then they had that reaction when johnny
said uh that they were having a baby and
we thought you know it was going to be
more of a generic reaction where they
were going to get like what you're
having a baby and then he subverted our
expectations i'm just really curious did
ryan johnson direct that scene or i
don't know
no because if he did johnny would have
thrown the baby over his shirt that's
true that's true okay
but the one question we want to know
greg is what did you think of the last
jedi uh i i find her very appreciated
inside joke guys this so far i think not
to interrupt the ryan his trilogy might
still happen guys but uh i think so far
this season at least to my eyes has done
a really nice job of being a very
satisfying and addictive binge
but i feel like each episode has been
well-rounded yeah and i feel like i
could watch these spaced out and still
be like i'm loving this you know yeah
yeah definitely
all right
enough out of all you
guys running this video now
with a patron of the day shout out
kevin
kev kevin
my goodness you came here the right time
oh boy because we just looked up your
name on urban dictionary it's a doozy
a kevin especially a second generation
kevin
is such a sweet and handsome man that
everyone wants to get to know clearly a
kevin wrote this
he never fails to make you laugh you
know every kevin i've known
has been mediocrely funny
that's all you need kevin is always
there when you need him and knows
exactly what to say at the right time
usually the kevin's i know we usually
have a gap in communication and
oftentimes i'm left offended uh however
yeah sometimes they're right and no
matter how stubborn you may be a kevin
knows how to bring you back down to
earth usually my craziest drug times
were with kevin he is very calm and
level-headed definitely kind of fist
fights with him yeah kevin a kevin can
talk to you for hours and the
conversation never gets old usually i'm
like
yeah i've heard this story before he is
a very good listener kevin's are always
interrupted man what are we talking
about who who makes you see things in
ways you would never dream of seeing
otherwise yeah like hatred for kevin's
kevin can be quite the head turner but
he is always loyal oh every kevin i've
bad business deals with everyone i've
ever known
left and right he deeply cares about
trust and it can be extremely hard to
earn it back once it's gone i don't know
about that
a lot of nights
actually i don't know about that okay i
won't go there
kevin love loves passionately and once
he has fallen for someone special he
would do anything and everything in his
power to keep her that's true i knew
kevin once who chained a girl and she
wasn't going anywhere for years rotted
uh he always knows how to make you feel
like the most beautiful and special girl
in the world
yeah i mean there's change is like the
reward
very special there's no other woman's
coming in that room nobody else is going
through that
there is never a dull moment with kevin
yeah oh man you know you go visit him in
jail and i'm telling you the stories
that he has
wow you might get pulled into a brawl
those stories never get old that's for
sure well kevin you sound like a great
guy so i'm happy to have you here on our
patreon page thanks for being here
[Music]